we [ __ ] around here right just when
you thought it was safe
Demi what's the story
mad flavor here a lot of people give me
[ __ ]
because like to torture people and
target let me tell you something when
you're ugly you could torture other ugly
[ __ ] people I don't know if you check
that I'm Noah you know that flavors
whirl
let's do this [ __ ] Dodger
Stadium [ __ ] waverly place bars on
his birthday normal salad [ __ ] kebab my
wife forget about it
Lisa Lisa Nicole Jam
maskull evil that's how we do it
stay back
look at this dozen here look at this
look at this cruel criminals here [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ]
look at these [ __ ] here look at
this baby no confession
look at these sets of criminals here and
see the blue cheese or go [ __ ] your
mother this is ha
these guys are ahead of the [ __ ] game
in San Jose this beautiful [ __ ] girl
right there little bit sexy savage right
there look at this [ __ ] cop taking
pictures of me while I'm taking pictures
of him [ __ ] we're here in San Jose
improv this is why I go on the road cuz
these crazy [ __ ] oh I got
Gorilla Biscuits I show him the [ __ ]
bag this guy showed up with a [ __ ]
fight and of course look at this [ __ ]
you understand me people this is what's
crack-a-lackin' here oh [ __ ] there goes
the fight [ __ ] it happens it's good your
spirits wanted something hey black
[ __ ] my flavors world with the
[ __ ] shield's on I can't see so don't
even ask I'm going to show you my main
man Dimmie how he sits next to my got
this Polian man next to me all day and
these [ __ ] come by they
scratched me you know who look at this
guy
Demi Demi what's the story huh
say hello to your balloons tail he's
always up to something this [ __ ]
Demi what's going on [ __ ] smoker huh huh
what's going on say hello
that's my boy always good for a [ __ ]
I love you people
get the [ __ ] out a [ __ ] second people
Joey couple days in on the set the
Raging Bull - that's how I roll
it's like a [ __ ] car from 1910 or
whatever the [ __ ] it is these are the
guys playing cards over here I'm playing
Mickey I own this joint I'm waiting for
[ __ ] force or being overcome is my
mind [ __ ] of a week the Raging Bull -
get the [ __ ] out huh who's better
than mad flavor if you had a Dodger game
you got to do the way tell them that
when they come and what's that one
you got it away you got to the way
pull my pants up and [ __ ] because when I
wave my pants fell down everybody's here
the birthday boy Felipe Esparza and with
San Juan say hello hello have our
flavors work and a little [ __ ] sir there
you got my beautiful one there you go
but flavor the Dodger game look at that
it comes the wave again but just wave
that way
away it comes the wave again there it
comes oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] here it comes
that's fell down again I'm at the
doctor's office I just got my physical I
got some blood taken out and I didn't
faint
[ __ ] how's that I got my scale I got
everything checked now I'm ready for the
Dolce guy he's inside
you got to do this first have a great
day mad flavor here at the [ __ ]
YMCA the Dolce died I'm still on the
diets going great some of the food
tastes like dick but what he gonna do
here on 10 was trying to stay healthy
I'm wearing a shirt - is the shirt I
used to wear when I was 415 pounds is
when I started working out with it
smells like a [ __ ] dead dick but it's
a reminder that I'm a fat [ __ ]
and I gotta get in here you understand
me so good luck with the Dolce died I
hope it's working out for you
[ __ ] it's going to work out for
me thirty forty pounds by November I
love you guys bye Joey Diaz here for the
Dolce diet on the bicycle of debt 28
minutes I'm going for 40 outside at the
wireless place one bag a [ __ ] bicycle
it's leaking oil the [ __ ] black
machine and that [ __ ] whatever
there's AB machine and that little thing
there but I'm working out that's all
that matters boy liquors math flavor
representing Dolce look at me like a
[ __ ] Savage listen to Lennox get it
Street survivors it makes me want to
come in here and rip on these [ __ ]
bicycles apart working like a savage my
weight is 300
and two pounds 302 I told you I was a
fat [ __ ] but that's all we started love
you today we're outs forget [ __ ]
target at the deli department here look
this guy
Lulu's cousin texting there
won't take you through a view of that
Iraqi steak like you'll be back I'm I
rouse my Dolce again the best fish in
the world check it out yeah look at that
local hallowed birthday Ellen that's my
girl got some salmon and some other sand
a little nuts this week Mike Dolce check
it out nice fish there
put your recipe together look at that I
got some fresh local halibut fillet
wild-caught got that frozen [ __ ] you get
at the other places this is round
[ __ ] we don't mess around okay boom
check it out
little fish dolce style you see I'm
saying a little lemon a little pepper a
little salt
look at this pooches [ __ ] muchas home
check bazaar
you want some great great you want some
you want some you want something
check this out should lose a little mind
right here there you go
living like doctors like mad flavor feel
Amanda Joey go Cody is Murph the parser
and the check this out
marching there that's we do it that's
how we do it man flavors one week were
in [ __ ] Columbus the next thing I
wanna set with my man [ __ ] Paul
Sorvino doing Raging Bull too much life
and on CC with my favorite [ __ ] dog
right there look this is where it all
goes down brother right here look at all
this [ __ ] I had on CC from Obama og the
[ __ ] lambsbread old-school big diesel
not to mention when you look at your
[ __ ] whatever this is over here you
look at the card and it tells you how
much ta see em you understand me where
do you get that type action from [ __ ]
they even tell you what's in the [ __ ]
thing 20% Louie the [ __ ] 16 is where
you get your paper pens look they're
[ __ ] sold out look at the tools look
at that [ __ ]
so next time you tell me you got the
same [ __ ] in your neighborhood then
we're smoking out here go shoot yourself
in the [ __ ] eye say hello to these
[ __ ]
it's a look at our charlyk scale winging
it [ __ ] around here alright just when
you thought it was safe look at the
board of life get the [ __ ] plants
that's how we're doing it here
[ __ ] like Snoop Dogg at 94 man I
love this game
yeah that's right stay black you
Australia oh yeah the Irishman I love
these motherf